this is chilly Ted chelated to shoot it
I guess I don't know I didn't get the
title on Italy and now a million
comments gonna be a campaign fest so
sorry I didn't catch on oh oh backwards
it's dit elledge how can you not know
what that is nothing thank you thank you
for sharing that yeah my life is so much
richer now thank you
it just wanted to help you actually took
away much from me by doing that no do
this your damn self much like how lapis
is trying to do it her to himself yes
tie it it all came back um so this is an
episode where we try to figure out
what's going on with lapis it was it
Jasper Jasper what was the name of the
evil one oh dude she's damn self okay so
the evil one is down there and she's
still trying to keep her down there and
it looks like they're fusing together to
be called malachite which as you know we
kind of like that name so I'm totally
down for that umm and yeah
Steen is just trying to show the gems
out dream oh you know how to sleep at a
dream and stuff why would pearl not
dream that that's an interesting uh I
mean she did she did eventually but
she's like I don't think of her a dream
before how does it work so it's
fascinating maybe the ideas - would be
put in their head for it to work I don't
know thanks for having that it's Jasper
by the way with you thank you what I say
then first you tried to say Jesper Oh
Jasper well Jasper meant Casper with a J
got it um just as friendly as you can
see it she's a rock but I thought she
was you know it's like she was always
like threatening like you know but we
didn't see much of her but something
about this one just seeing like the idea
that she could come back and when you
see you're trying to reach for Steven
and stuff it's like yet and if you want
to know what a pearl doesn't dream it's
because she's too neurotic to dream
requires surrendering yourself to your
ear that's very good next but no no I
will not give it to the chaos
well obviously they visualize do it
looks like oh but now do the rescue
O'Day himself but I really need you
you're my fusion okay if you get your
head off me I'll participate I'm gonna
have to wash this thing twincest
um even though he's already that's brief
that's breaking down the world's cuz
that's gravity falls gravity falls in
Steven universe can't man Rob that's in
the past gravity falls is gone
no God God is that Wow season three
reunion is lightly maybe possible what
the creator said but most unlikely
unlikely my cleats give me so many
Steven universe fans are just like tire
um so now I like the idea that um you
know this is you know showing him out a
dream the dream sequences are pretty
cool and yeah it does kind of give us
more insight to what is going on with
lapis I mean not that we got a ton but
certainly you see that's a constant
fight iczer like seeing mentally inside
how that fight works I thought was a
very cool idea sort of them like you
know one is kind of trying to drag the
other under the water it's almost like
what was this he saw where the two had
to keep balance it was kind of like that
it's nothing really balancing I just
think they're chained to each other so
it's almost like there's an invisible
tunnel underneath the ocean and you pull
one the other one goes in you pull the
other yeah no but that's why I'm saying
it's like what it's a time for KF if I
have control no actually I thought that
was a great image I thought that it was
really amazing
um not as great of an image as pearl
riding on roses back and Rose turning
into Stevens dead and then barfing a
pizza tongue I was his / her it snows
but now that's pretty creepy when that
pizza was coming up the tongue ha like
that yeah she's we add it to the list of
pearls dossier of I'll tell you the
evidence is really building I was like
this poor girl has a lot of issues
I just I good now that I've seen her
dreamworld I'm like yeah I feel even
more sorry well I guess Stevens Eliza's
emails and issue issues to come to grips
away at the end she's the one that might
not only might be changing teens but
changing T's for someone that like stole
her over yeah well I need it seems
obvious pearls in love with Rose it just
did but that's not the issue it's it's
the poor way that it's a love triangle
and she can't get over it no I like that
son Lee did so say I just love that she
see Stephens dad they're like you know
hey just like wha but it's like her mind
kind of put him there too and stuff so
well because he stole her that her let's
right through the galaxy together would
that be like an interesting like Karl is
the most fascinating character to be my
hands down I love garnet and amethyst
I'm like pearl I'm like man it's like
peeling an onion just every new layer
you kids how addressing would that be if
like she goes by and like she actually
gets an attraction for Steven stand I
would just be so messed up cuz this is
the guy that kind of stole her love you
know like that would just be like so
that Betty don't see that happening no
probably not but just that he's so
intriguing it's like she's so messed up
anyway I don't know is she by I know I
kind of just figured no I think they're
all just attracted to their own kind I
think like it - technically roses the
buy one because she went for someone
this yeah no but I was asking that about
a girl I did is it how it works
I just nothing's indicated I assumed he
was like human sexuality so it's just a
hetero homo by like but III think with
or or likes transgender I did again with
the gems that like modern society gets
confusing sometimes but it anyway yeah I
just forget it was it was just like our
world so she could be ahead well I mean
clearly I think if she's into Rose
there's that but whether it's that or by
I well no because here's the thing with
the gems and like we never see they
never say whether or not they actually
like have sags and procreate or anything
it sounds sure they show
drogyn is the concept of like gender and
human sexuality would just confuse them
and to see that's my thought because we
we start you never seen a guy generally
just about pure love I without all of
the other physical attached I mean we
never have seen a a male gem in any of
this race I'm really lean towards that
they don't exist so you know this is
sort of the image and there are some
that thing dwarf women don't distance oh
that's a silly though well which I think
makes even more sense why Rose would be
attracted you know to someone that's
different like in a whole new you know
creation and stuff I don't know I not
because some totally do and they haven't
seen it before that's another story for
down the road I guess we yeah we don't
know yet
but the audience will tell us but that's
why I don't me to come near do I already
had a couple of Steven universe things
blown for me now cuz I read it by
accident other people posting elsewhere
in like other groups like and I'm like
I see the only way I ever have
anything ruined is by like if I'm on
like tumblr deviantART or something like
that like there's a fan art of something
missus it was not banner but like a lot
of fan arts cuz people do fan art it was
about when there's a ton of a repeating
in it was one of our other like
producers fan pages uh and that I belong
to and like somebody was posting about
Steven universe and so I'm like
scrolling through Facebook and I'm like
oh I don't read the comments I don't if
somebody post comments on my wall about
Steven universe I scan ahead a little
but I'm kind of like one I clothes like
just to me I'd read it yeah like so but
but damn it so but uh yeah it's nice so
I kind of made the assumption that life
is was gonna come back well for its way
oh yeah well way too interesting a
character wait too good at design well
now distortion and Emily yeah I mean it
seems like she'd have to come back so I
mean it didn't surprise me uh you know
but again we're we're not getting a ton
I mean we do see visually how works and
we know there's some sort of fusion
making this Malakai thing but we don't
know a ton of like too much more about
it we didn't know before so yeah I mean
it will be cool to see even more like
how that progresses and stuff um by the
way garnets
way of falling asleep is also my my to
jar while we need to hurry even it's
like gone if you put if you turn the TV
on
and put me in a bed or on a couch like
if you've got a few minutes about yeah
no it's I can pretty much sleep anywhere
the my wife I think you said your wife
is the same is like takes forever to
like nope
yeah no it takes it for a long time I've
had a bunch of caffeine right before I
go to bed sure but otherwise it makes me
even more tired but I'm a freak that way
um I said like your super-secret mutant
power Pickers yeah I get some caffeine
no caffeine like especially in coffee
actually makes me relaxed and tired are
you sure you're not just getting a
caffeine high and then crashing an hour
later I don't I whenever people have
ordered coffee like at the end of dinner
I always put together that it's like oh
like you have coffee to serve relax like
it's the end of the evening I never put
together that people it's to keep them
up to keep them staying up because it
always made me want to sleep yeah but
see my problem with ordering coffee at
the end of dinner is if you're doing it
you're eating out and odds are you've
just had a big meal it's only to just
wake you up back to the base level cuz
honestly you're just gonna be tired
still anyway cuz you see to me it just
relaxes me that's always what I thought
of with coffee
but I know I'm I'm the weirdo I'm the
one like you know I I have coffee in the
morning with my friend or room if a
thinks they have a nice relaxing stop
were just a uten power ever I agree it's
really stupid I don't know why what's
your secret powered coffee makes me
tired
yeah that's why energy drinks none of
that does anything for me bro tells me I
don't need them anyway like solo seems a
nightmare on elm street when they're all
drinking coffee that you would have been
dead you would have been Freddy Krueger
Shishkin yeah no that that would have
been the first to die cuz you've been
drinking going like oh but I don't like
I go to sleep so fast and I sleep so
deeply but it's like I have a ton of
energy the rest of the day so it's like
I don't need coffee I don't need energy
drinks aren't you perfect well no cuz I
don't see how if I need more energy I
can't get it there's nobody for me to
get it I just leap well that's how I get
more energy and meet me at you give me
energy
so you're like Mega Man but if you get
an energy
it drains your energy kind of or it's
like a different wow we're really not
okay even you were freak
yeah okay no I only knew that but let's
talk about Steven universe oh I think
we're done i what else was there besides
the return of dog captor that was
amazing don't captor I like garnets
goggles come back and well those how
pearl described the life preservers as
wife diapers I was pretty fun that's
kind of true I always felt like like on
a cruise ship when they do like the the
drills or whatever and you have to get
the life checking at any time I've worn
a life jacket I felt like a two-year-old
yeah I feel like a toddler like yeah
yeah yeah you need unlike me very I'm
not saying that exhibit Rob Walker says
don't use your life just anti
lifejackets I'm anti life uh I just
that's how I feel though it's like that
you cannot look dignified in a life
jacket it is impossible the people are
the Titanic looks so funny well they
didn't care they were dead um kiss you
look there's a Titanic - there's an
animated Titanic no no I'm serious they
actually built a replica of the ship and
it's gonna sail and it's called Titanic
- really yeah and honestly that's too
soon wait we're really getting saya here
so I got it up no this is a funny
episode that also has some nice you know
served our cryptic stuff it ties into
the story I open I liked it for the most
part outside of Ronaldo uh most of these
have been good episodes that are
furthering the plot yeah I feel like I'm
learning more and more faster and faster
about what's going on and I enjoy that
but we're still we're also learning more
about like their culture and how they
act I'm trying to understand dreaming
and stuff like that and it's one of
those things where I don't know it's
hard for me to get tired of that cliche
that should be more of this human thing
or whatever but leads to something great
analogy it's like I love that you know
in their dreams they're usually hard to
explain which is why we're really boring
to us it's like the moment of that nail
the most true moment in the
in the show was yeah when you tell other
people about dreams then it suddenly
becomes boring yeah that is so true no I
thought that was so well point whatever
people tell me like the weirdest room
they start telling me at first it's like
oh hey this will be interesting at about
like 30 seconds into it I'm like yeah
why you gotta tell me a dream anybody
keep it short oh I don't need or add
more nudity yes keep it short add more
nudity maybe some violence it's like the
Internet yeah pretty much um so yeah
that's about it we will see you at the
next one late